all right welcome to Hannity tonight Dr
fauci confronted on Capitol Hill with
the truth as he was grilled today by
Senator Rand Paul he will join us with a
recap also tonight Wisconsin Senate
candidate Mandela Barnes was caught on
camera trashing capitalism this after he
called for violent criminals to be
released from prison we're going to play
uh that tape and vet him tonight but
first the countdown continues we are
only 55 short days away from these
pivotal midterm elections and Democrats
have lost all touch with reality now
yesterday we showed you the new
devastating economic numbers inflation
went up cornflation went up food rent
energy all way up the stock market
meanwhile plummeted it tanked it dropped
significantly the biggest drop since the
height of the pandemic now this but one
month after the Democrats passed their
so-called inflation reduction act or as
I call it the taxi poor middle class and
people on fixed income Act of 2022 it
doesn't actually do anything to reduce
inflation it will increase inflation it
is just a massive Green New Deal
spending bill that as predicted is
making inflation far worse making
everything more expensive than ever and
now by the way to add insult to injury
Biden's incompetent Transportation
secretary small town mayor does Mayor
Pete right there has been unable to
hammer out a deal with America's
railroad unions so now in the wake of a
looming strike many train lines are
getting shut down and our supply chain
problems are about to get that much
worse even certain Amtrak routes have
already been put on pause indefinitely
Joe Amtrak Joe do you care to comment so
naturally none of this stop the White
House from throwing a massive
celebration complete with the smiling
and the fist bumps and the laughing and
the padding on the back with Nancy
Pelosi even had a live performance from
James Taylor hey he's serenaded the
crowd with Fire and Rain it's a great
song song about drug addiction and
suicide perhaps maybe appropriate in
this sense given Biden's Fentanyl and
opioid crisis because of his open
borders policies now a celebration
patting themselves on the back on the
day that inflation numbers Rose yet
again from the previous month can you
really be that oblivious and that out of
touch with the American people because
Americans are suffering now the
president even treated his guests to a
rage-filled celebratory speech complete
with weird bizarre anger yelling about
how Joe Biden himself rescued America's
economy and fixed inflation what world
is he living in be a party crasher but
and by the way this uh all the news
networks featured live side by side
footage look at that they were showing
the stock market crashing even fake news
CNN msdnc they seemed absolutely shocked
that Joe Biden Biden was spiking the
football at the very moment Americans
retirement funds were being wiped out in
real time Joe's bizarre celebration
didn't stop there today he visited the
Detroit Auto Show as Tucker just showed
you the Z06 that's a great looking
Corvette now just three weeks after Ford
announced they were laying off 3 000
employees to cut costs and pay for the
Biden administration's electric vehicle
transition of course that didn't stop
Joe Biden from having a little fun as he
got behind the wheel of car after car
after car and then bizarrely held hands
with the Michigan Governor Gretchen
Whitmer but later after a brief set of
remarks Joe faced a serious challenge he
couldn't seem to remember how to get
down from the podiums like when he
shakes air so often pretty common
problem for Joe take a look
thank you
[Music]
sorry it appears Joe Biden has some
serious issues with short-term memory
his vice president meanwhile just that
simple trouble with something called the
truth you decide
every year gas powered cars and trucks
and buses contribute millions of tons
of carbon dioxide and toxic air
pollution
but there is a solution to this problem
electric vehicles
electric cars and trucks and buses which
produce no tailpipe emissions
and they are cheaper to own
they are not cheaper to own that would
be called where I grew up a flat out lie
the average cost of an electric vehicle
is twenty two thousand dollars more than
a gas powered car not to mention the
additional energy costs to charge the
vehicle and of course you have to
pillage Mother Earth with big heavy
equipment that's run on diesel fuel
mining for these Rare Minerals and and
pillaging them out of the earth never
mind the fossil fuels that you'll
actually need to plug in the car because
that represents 90 percent of our
current electric grid and even with the
high price of gas it would take at least
a decade plus to maybe even break even
so common is just flat out lying or just
hasn't bothered to do simple math so for
the two-thirds of Americans those of you
out there that are suffering living
paycheck to paycheck I've been there it
sucks it's not fun electric vehicles are
not a solution to any of your problems
but fear not the Biden Administration
they have another solution if you are
one one of the many U.S soldiers in
other words the real heroes in this
country and you're struggling to put
food on the table and make ends meet the
administration is now publicly
encouraging and Advising our brave
military the people that preserve our
freedoms to apply for food stamps what a
repulsive National embarrassment think
about this we're now sending over 50
billion dollars to Ukraine but our
soldiers aren't making enough here at
home to buy enough food to to feed their
family this is beyond appalling Biden
just spent what trillions on inefficient
solar panels and wind turbines we're
decades away from this alternative
energy or renewable energy Independence
as Pete Peter Pete Boot and judge once
and Jennifer Graham home wants and they
want to spend trillions more to bail out
social justice majors in college who
willingly took out massive student loans
they did it willingly they signed their
name to the loan and meanwhile American
armed service men and women left to hang
out to dry go get food stamps how about
you take the student loan forgiveness
money make the people that borrow to pay
it back and pay the people that protect
the freedom so these kids can even
attend school and make sure they can
afford to put food on their table of
course the Department of Defense did
find room in their budget to hire a
cheap diversity equity and inclusion
officer or as she refers to herself a
woke administrator and according to a
recent Fox news.com report the dod's
woke administer administrator openly
disparaged white people online because
of their race since the report much of
our social media has been deleted and
Fox News digital did not immediately
hear a response from the Department of
Defense they are waiting breathlessly
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else